[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm
bothered by the thought of you hating
your father
i don't like you carrying that around
with you
also i don't quite feel your father
warrants it
this coming from the person who wants to
strangle him
can i ask you a very dramatic question
yes
why did you have me in the first place
ah that is
dramatic
well it wasn't planned of course
i thought i couldn't have children
i had never wanted one
then when it happened we thought
your presence could help us come
together
and well you were a last-ditch effort
in effect
but then when he saw you it
clarified something for him he turned
away forever from you
and me both
but i shouldn't hate him
your father is an emotional [ __ ]
but he isn't evil
what happened when you saw me
i've never been so hurt
by something in my life is when i saw
your face for the first time
why
because you were your father
because you were me
because you were all three of us
so ruinous
and why did you come to me when you did
that was strange wasn't it it was
unexpected
i wanted you to come you know but i
wanted you to come for so long that when
you finally did i was confused
i'm sorry i know
but don't be i was happy really what are
you
yes i didn't know you were you
i'd have come right away if i had
i'd never have let you go in the first
place
you understand what it did for me
yes i hope you do
i do
[Music]
lucas michelle that's such a great scene
that really
pulls together everything that the two
characters have kind of been
not saying to each other for the whole
film uh
you uh adapted the film from a book by
uh patrick dewitt who also wrote the
screenplay
uh let's talk about this scene and sort
of uh what it says about the
film as a whole how about from the
actor's point of view because this is
really a
point where you get to say something
that most
mother-son dynamics never get to work
through
what what did that feel like after uh
after having played the characters
to this point it was so heartbreaking
because what i
and sometimes you don't even realize
what it is you're playing what the story
really is
until you're in the moment and then
things happen and then you understand
and i and i thought the the tragedy
of this mother living this narcissistic
existence
and being absent for so long
and finally realizing in this moment
how much she really loves her son and
how much time has been lost that
you know she'll never get back and
um so it's a very bittersweet moment
it didn't feel very much like a scene to
me it really just felt like
we we got to it it felt like intimacy
um and and uh i i loved i loved that
uh azzazo will you tell us sort of how
you uh
how you kind of clicked on this project
in the first place because if patrick
had written the book
and had done the adaptation was it
something that
sort of landed in your lap or uh did you
come in earlier in the process it came
in pretty
very very early in the process before
the book was finished because patrick
and i are very close friends so we share
material with each other in really late
stages
before things are finished when we can
still chime in and uh
and this one when i read i immediately
just
fell for and the moment i finished i
asked him if i could
start working on turning the film so
even the the adaptation began
as a conversation before the book was
finished once michelle and lucas got
involved
they were really involved in as well in
terms of
valuing the book taking things that they
cared for and found there helped them
get into their characters
and then talking with both patrick and i
and so michelle matt met with pat and i
and so did lucas and
and that kind of really went through all
the way through
shooting i mean there was the book we'd
keep going back to
and keep finding things that as the even
while we're shooting we realized oh
that's
actually very very helpful and that is
actually one of the things that happened
in in this particular scene as well in
terms of something that was in the
script
but there was one particular section
where she says you know all because
he goes why and he goes she goes because
you're all three of us
myself um you know your father all three
of us are weirders and that's really
michelle harping on you harping on you
and saying why do i say this why do i
say this
and then i was reading the book and then
there was just this one
passage and it was that passage and it
was because you were all three of us
so ruinous and i
that's why i said it and um you know
so throughout filming it was you know
that process it was a constant process
like that
there's such a beautiful heightened
language to the
to the novel and that carries over into
the film and
and it must be a real delight to play
but maybe also difficult
because you know uh real people don't
necessarily
talk so eloquently but these are such
educated
you know uh they're they're
they're characters you know who are
larger than life
uh you know what um uh was that a
challenge ever to kind of like fit the
the
that sort of music of their um of their
dialogue or was that
half of the appeal i i was daunted by
that
and um i and i i
as much as i loved this writing and this
character
i thought how how am i going to
own this speech and um
and and then though you you you just it
just becomes you
well there's this feeling almost that
kind of theatricality to
uh to the character and it never crosses
over
into camp and in and it's but it's big
you know it's like she's always on
her own stage of her own life you know
the spotlight is always on her
and it allows her to kind of monologue
sometimes or to say
it's almost you know for someone who's
extemporaneously as as
clever as witty as this character that's
a lot to sell
um as an actress it's a fine line and
and
and sometimes you you you go under it
and when it should be heightened a
little bit more and sometimes you
you cross over you know and it's just
it's just finding that line really sort
of
scene by seeing and and i and i do think
that that's the
the thing about aza is that he's he's
you know he's able to sort of
brilliantly combine
these very different tones and that was
the balancing
act that we were what we were walking
continually
you know every day on the film and all
of the characters really is it would
it would go into sort of humor and and
and and silliness and and
right before it's threatening to sort of
spiral out of control
you know ozzy will insert and patrick
you know uh moments of melancholy to
kind of bring it down to reality
lucas in real life have you ever
interacted with the character anything
like uh the francis when you're playing
opposite and how did you sort of
uh find your footing i don't think so
yes you know i i've i i know
maybe one who has a similar kind of
like when you look her in the face it's
like you it feels like you're talking to
us
to like somebody who belongs in the
world of like statues in a way like and
i don't mean that in a
reductive sense i mean i'm just like
there's a grandness and a kind of like
makes you makes you you sort of feel
like a potato standing next to them
so um so
i would say yes maybe but
i see all of patrick's world and i don't
see this as as an exception
being a world that he's made made up
um and and is a reflection of his
imagination i i i'm not somebody who's
like
you're gonna walk go to the upper east
side and see malcolm walking around
like you're not gonna um
meet a roald dahl character on the
street like i i don't i think they
they help us they help us understand the
world we live in but
what makes them so exciting is that
there there's a there's a freedom there
that we don't encounter in the real
world
nothing really prepared me for it other
than
uh michelle's characterization
of of francis which which which was
really i mean i
i've read the book a few times and read
the script but
not until i met the character was i
really there with her
kind of reminded in the in the scene of
that that sort of great scene at the end
of call me by your name between
you know father and son where there's
this kind of impossible conversation
that none of us have in the real world
of you know kind of
things that you know never get to be
said and yet the the film
this film you know does it in such a
surprising way and i think every
every admission she makes starts with
half of a phrase that makes you think
it's going to go one way
and then it sort of veers into something
very sincere and revealing
i mean it's a really tricky moment
because
you're you're doing this this thing
that's not just a catharsis for the
character but for anyone who has
parents which all of us do you know um
would you maybe talk at all about uh
just the like you know making sure
like we've been talking about treading
the line but making sure you did it from
the
the screenwriting point of view in this
scene what you brought up with
thinking that france is going to say uh
and then going to a different direction
like
malcolm asking you know
what was like to when she saw
when she saw him and i've never been
hurt more hurt than anything in my own
life it's so surprising
to me that that's what she's going to
say but it's so direct and it's like
it's
it's what you're saying to have such a
direct conversation
um i think is is so rare
between especially between parents and
their children
and i think at the same time malcolm
knows that she answers things completely
truthfully so i
i think one of the conversations that
lucas and i had
which is like how long has malcolm
wanted to ask why did you have me like
is this the question that he's
been carrying for 12 years and why is it
now that he's asking this and where is
that coming from and is that coming from
the place
of realizing that the potential that
anger that his mother has
is so for for his father so
deep that she could have killed him and
then i think
something that also happens and maybe
this happens at a different place from
michelle but in my mind part of this
conversation
francis francis is um
letting go of a lot of the hate and
anger and then
the desire to kill her husband goes
in this conversation yeah i mean it all
sort of circles back the whole movie is
kind of driven by this
this selfishness this thing that she
says about you know my plan was to die
before the money ran out
and that leaves anyone else but namely
malcolm
kind of in the lurch and this is the
scene that tells us that he's gonna be
okay that he's getting the closure that
so many children don't get from their
parents
but um i mean you really spare us the
brutality of
what she does in this film but it's
implied and um or what she will do
you know um and uh and you need this
thing to land
for everything that followed to work
especially in the execution where i
really feel like that's
from here on out is where the movie
really goes its own way it's
it's presenting the same information in
your way
from from the novel it really was um
like like michelle said we waited to the
very end
of shooting this so this really was the
last day that we're shooting this
section in there so what that
which is natural of course you don't
want to dive into something way too
early we're all still getting to know
each other and trust each other
and know these characters and understand
it so by the time we get to this place
the the best chance of what you're
talking about could be could happen
but also meant that there was this um
at least this immense weight to actually
even going into
this scene because um
a lot of ways it was a good buy from for
me
with with francis and with the shooting
itself how did you create that dynamic
because
you know there's a big jump in time
between her picking
malcolm up at boarding school and the
next scene where they're at
breakfast together and yet it's equally
plausible
in that next scene that they've spent
kind of every moment of the last years
together that dynamic exists
presumably very early in the shooting
i can see how it pays off that you work
up to this big scene but again
you know the there's there's no lack of
that
dynamic um throughout a lot of what
informed
even the directing of young malcolm by
that time i'd spent
a good six months talking with lucas and
figuring out and discussing
malcolm so some of that rhythm
just transferred over i think in terms
of the conversations that i had with
with the young actor that was playing
welcome and so
that continuation i found so much just
in terms of the walk in terms of the way
that young malcolm just walks down that
hallway
that there's something that continues
straight over into this next scene that
you kind of feel like
okay from this moment on it really is
the next day that
it even if it's been 12 years later this
is
this is there's a continuity between
these moments that's
seamless even the way that we shot it
with it kind of
starting the same thing with young
malcolm walking away from camera and
then hold their mouth
and walk away from the camera and just
replicating that frame
so that these things are could join to a
place where you just feel like
okay this has been that this has been
the beginning of his life and this has
been his entire life
and lucas and michelle would you say
anything about your process in terms of
building that bond earlier in the in
your shared performance
i mean if you spent months preparing did
you were you in
conversation with each other during this
time i
i like to think that if you get if you
create a really great world
which was given to us and you have
somebody who helps facilitate that world
and you have two people who really want
to be there and are sensitive to it
that's that's all that is needed for
chemistry
um i will say that
yeah we did we didn't really talk a
whole lot we met
once i think to read through some of the
script and then we had a little
rehearsal time in montreal
and um and i think we've just really
loved the story and we're like
open and vulnerable to the to the
project and
and aza was just such a beautiful mother
to us
i did of that all of that
congratulations to you all the
i mean i think the film really is and
you make it
look uh you know so natural
thank you thank you very much appreciate
it thank you